欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。同学们,第四小节我们来讲一下关于RTS与定制产品标题有什么样的区别。这其实是有一定的区别的。为什么呢?他们的人群不一样。他们所描述的产品的精准度都是不一样的。首先呢,标题决定流量的精准性。决定循环的转化率。因为我们在做运营的过程中已经测试过。
而不同的关键词,它的属性不一样,决定转化大小是不一样的。比如说大词,它可能就是点击量非常多,但是它的转化相对偏低。精准词跟长尾词,它点击量稍微少一点,但是它的转化比较高。所以说我们平时在收集关键词,以及去判断关键词的时候,一定要非常的清楚,每一个关键词的属性,或者是它的
买家客户需求的表达。这样才能够更好的去把握我们推广的一些关键词。首先,在发产品上面,RTS发产品的时候,我们首先是侧重的是产品的款式,然后是用精准词为主的去发产品。为什么要注重款式呢?你看RTS是不是,它主要就是直接下单的产品,客户主要就是找款,或者是找品为主的。
那么找品找款为主,那么你的款式可能会很差,或者是你的产品不好,那么你是不是就会直接影响到你的
循环转化。另外一个就是你的标题所描述的这些词,所用的这些词去描述的这个产品,如果描述的跟你的实际的产品都不符合,客户收出来之后发现你的词跟品不匹配,或者是说词
这种品的差异度比较大的时候,他是不是就会不点击,或者是点击进去发现跟我的想法不一样,那么是不是他就会放弃给你发旋盘,就是这么一个逻辑,然后就是你看这个款是不是会有很多针对这个款式的一些比较精准的词去描述,所以说这样就是以精准词为主,比如说你用的款式,比如说蓝色,还有一些属性的
还有一些功能的词,这些都是比较
比较精准的词,所以说你在发RTS的时候,一定要用精准的词去描述这一款产品。这样的话,搜索出来的结果更加准确,获得的一个转化率会更高一点。那么接下来我们讲一下关于定制链接发的时候,我们要注意哪些类型。定制的客户
这个客户是不是他主要是找某一类产品,找某一类产品,记住这句话,找某一类产品,一类产品。那么他找一类产品是不是他对
这个产品
是什么样的属性,什么样的功能
什么样的
色彩或者是风格
他自己心里面可能也不是特别的清楚
所以说呢,我们在主标题的时候,就重点
在于产品类型,比如说你同一款产品是不是
同一款产品里面是不是会有几种风格
或者是几种功能
或者是几种属性不一样
你就侧重于
这几个
侧重于这几个的话,那么你发的产品的时候所用的词
就是一些常规的通用词,通用词,而不是特质某一类的
通用词,比如说你这款产品有
红色、蓝色、白色、黑色
那么你用的词
你可能就在这里面,可能可以同时用这几个颜色都写在标题里面
为什么呢?因为客户找的是你这款产品,他对颜色可能还没有
明确的一个需求,但是他如果是通过颜色来搜索也能讲是你这款产品
因为他
进来不一定是说直接下单
红、蓝、白
这些颜色你可以在产品组图上面
不一定
都有这些颜色,那你只有一款颜色,你也是可以
先把客户引流进来,然后在详情页里面把这些
款式
给补充完整就可以了,所以在发定制产品链接的时候,我们的产品类型
一定要侧重的是产品类型
然后
用的词是
通用的词,通用的
通用的
然后就是
常规的一些词
比如说大词,还有精准词
我们来举个例子,比如说
你是做手机壳的
手机壳是不是会有很多很多型号
那么你同一系列的,比如说华为的
华为的手机壳
那么你同一系列,你是不是
有完全就说固定
A型号还是B型号是不是,还是C型号,你没有完全
完全确定
如果是你做定制的
那么你直接就
A,B,C,三种型号都可以放在同一个标题里面
因为
做A型号的跟B型号C型号的
都是华为手机
那么这个客户
所做的产品类型就是华为手机,所以说他需求的偏
需求的那些款式
或者是说他的型号是
很多的
所以说你做标题的时候就没有必要
单独写一个型号
你单独写一个型号也是可以,但是你覆盖的流量少
而且是能够命中客户的需求
就会偏低
如果是你产品的款式,如果是RTS的
那么你这里只写
A型号或者是只写B型号,只写C型号,一个链接,两个链接,三个链接
这样的话
就是我们常说的RTS链接
那么这里的是
ABC三个型号
都融合在
这一个链接里面
这样的话就是我们常规写的一个通用的
多款式
的一个
定制链接
这样
能够覆盖的流量
广
覆盖流量广
加上就是
稳定
稳定也比较符合就是能够满足
定制人群的
多样需求
因为这里看到的话
单独一款就是单一的需求
这里的话
一般做定制或者是
做批发的买家
他都是会
销售多种类型的产品的
所以我们要
尽量的满足他
多种类型
然后就是用词的话
一定是用大词跟精准词
偏多一点点
大词
跟精准词这一类的话
就是批发类的客户搜索的比较多一点点
因为批发的客户他本来是对于某一类产品的需求
但是他不明确是
这类产品里面
某个功能某个属性
他没有特定的要求
大部分是没有的
到后面才确定于
确定
某个功能某个属性的
但是呢我们RTS的话一般来说是小买家
一些网红
那么他
开始的时候他就直接非常清楚的知道
他就是要去找
好卖的产品
以及去找一些
当前市场上
比较畅销的
就是这个款式也比较明确的一些产品
所以说就这样的话就
你越精准那么他的转换就会越好
但是这里的话
定制你就越
广泛
加上
多样
那么他的转换就会相对来说
大一点点
这就是我们在发RTS产品和定制产品
标题的时候一定要做一点点区别
不要
全部都是一样的
所以说这个就是基于
用户的一个
需求行为
来做的标题
这样的标题才能够更加满足客户的一个
需求
才能够获得更多
的询盘
好了这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们还是继续讲关于标题的
随法